>>> GOOD EVENING.
SIX MORE TOP ADVISERS TO THE
FORMER PRESIDENT GOT WORD LATE
TODAY THAT THE HOUSE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON JANUARY 6th WANTS
TO TALK WITH THEM.
AND IT HAS WITH SO MANY OTHERS,
THE COMMITTEE ISN'T ASKING THEM,
IT IS TELLING THEM.
THE SIX ALL RECEIVING SUBPOENAS,
FIRST TO PRODUCE DOCUMENTS, THEN
APPEAR BEFORE THE COMMITTEE.
MOST ARE PRETTY FAMILIAR NAMES,
IF YOU FOLLOW THIS SORT OF
THING.
FORMER-NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISER
MICHAEL FLYNN, WHO IN DECEMBER
OF LAST YEAR REPORTEDLY TOOK
PART IN AN OVAL OFFICE MEETING
DURING WHICH PARTICIPANT US
DISCUSSED SEIZING VOTING
MACHINES AND EXERCISING
EMERGENCY POWERS.
ALSO, 2020 CAMPAIGN MANAGER BILL
STEPIEN.
FORMER-NEW YORK POLICE
COMMISSIONER AND PARDONED FELON
BERNIE KERIK WHO WAS PART OF THE
WILLARD HOTEL ROOM SET UP TO
OVERTURN THE ELECTION.
THEN, THERE IS JOHN EASTMAN, THE
PRESIDENT'S ATTORNEY WHO PUT
TOGETHER THAT MEMO WHICH AMOUNT
TODAY A STEP-BY-STEP GUIDE TO
THE FORMER PRESIDENT SPARKING A
COUP.
>> AND ALL WE ARE DEMANDING OF
VICE PRESIDENT PENCE IS THIS
AFTERNOON AT 1:00, HE LET THE
LEGISLATURES OF THE STATE LOOK
INTO THIS SO WE GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF IT AND THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE KNOW WHETHER WE HAVE
CONTROL OF THE DIRECTION OF OUR
GOVERNMENT OR NOT.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> RUDY GIULIANI APPLAUDING HIM
ON.
THAT WAS EASTMAN AT THE RALLY
LEADING UP TO THE INSURRECTION
LAYING OUT THE ESSENCE OF A MEMO
THAT WOULD ONLY COME TO LIGHT
MONTHS LATER, AND MIGHT NEVER
HAVE SEEN THE LIGHT OF DAY HAD
THE SCHEME ACTUALLY SUCCEEDED.
NOW, THE SELECT COMMITTEE WANTS
TO KNOW MORE.
THE QUESTION, THOUGH, IS WILL
THEY GET IT FROM HIM?
OR ANY OF THE OTHER FIVE?
OR ANY OF THE OTHERS THEY HAVE
SUBPOENAED?
TONIGHT, IT'S HARD TO SEE HOW.
ON FRIDAY, FORMER-JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL JEFFREY
CLARK, WHOM THE FORMER PRESIDENT
WANTED TO TAKE OVER THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, APPEARED BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE BUT REFUSED TO SPEAK
UNTIL THE QUESTION OF EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE MAKES IT THROUGH THE
COURTS.
THEN, THERE IS STEVE BANNON WHO
STIFF ARMED THE COMMITTEE
ENTIRELY AND WHOM CONGRESS HELD
IN CONTEMPT, REFERRING HIS CASE
TO THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
THAT WAS MORE THAN TWO AND A
HALF WEEKS AGO.
TODAY, ATTORNEY GENERAL MERRICK
GARLAND WAS ASKED TO COMMENT ON
IT.
HE DECLINED SAYING ONLY, QUOTE,
WE EVALUATE THESE IN THE NORMAL
WAY WE DO.
LOOKING AT THE FACTS AND LAW,
AND APPLYING PRINCIPLES OF
PROSECUTION.
KEEPING 'EM HONEST, THESE ARE
CERTAINLY NOT NORMAL TIMES, NOR
HAVE MANY OF THE BIG NAME
SUBPOENA RECIPIENTS, SO FAR,
RESPONDED IN ANY NORMAL WAY,
OTHER THAN WITH DELAY TACTICS,
STONEWALLING, OR IN BANNON'S
CASE, OUTRIGHT CONTEMPT.
QUITE AN EXAMPLE OF THE -- FOR
THE LATEST SIX TO FOLLOW.
JOINING US NOW IS CNN CHIEF
DOMESTIC CORRESPONDENT, JIM
ACOSTA.
ALSO, ELIZABETH HOLTZMAN, WHO IS
CONGRESSWOMAN FROM NEW YORK,
SERVED ON THE HOUSE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE DURING WATERGATE.
SO, OBVIOUSLY, THESE ARE STAUNCH
LOYALISTS OF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT IS THERE ANY REASON TO
THINK THEY WOULD CONSIDER
COOPERATING?
>> NO I THINK THESE SIX ARE ALL
GOING TO DIG IN, ANDERSON.
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME LOW-LEVEL
ASSOCIATES OF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT WHO HAVE BEEN
APPARENTLY COOPERATING TO SOME
EXTENT MAYBE BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
AFFORD THE LEGAL FEES.
BUT, YOU KNOW, THESE SIX.
THEY ARE -- THEY ARE PRETTY
INTEGRAL TO WHAT THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE IS INVESTIGATING.
TALK ABOUT JOHN EASTMAN WHO
WROTE THAT INFAMOUS MEMO TRYING
TO SAY THAT THE PRESIDENT -- THE
FORMER PRESIDENT -- THE FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT COULD THROW OUT
THE ELECTION RESULTS FROM THE
2020 ELECTION.
YOU HAVE JASON MILLER WHO WAS
CRAFTING STATEMENTS FOR THE
FORMER PRESIDENT AT THAT TIME.
YOU EVER BILL STEPIEN WHO WAS
THE CAMPAIGN MANAGER OF THE 2020
CAMPAIGN FOR THE FORMER
PRESIDENT.
SO, THESE ARE VERY IMPORTANT,
INFLUENTIAL PEOPLE IN THAT
PROCESS WHO ARE APPARENTLY
INVOLVED IN THAT -- THAT
INFAMOUS MEETING THAT WAS GOING
ON OVER AT THE WILLARD HOTEL
HERE IN WASHINGTON.
BUT, ANDERSON, I TALKED TO
FORMER-TRUMP ADVISER
EARLIER-THIS EVENING WHO SAID
LISTEN, YOU KNOW, IT LOOKS LIKE
WHAT THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE
IS DOING AND IT'S LOGICAL THAT
THEY ARE GOING TO DO THIS IS
TALK TO EVERY PERSON AROUND THE
FORMER PRESIDENT.
PERHAPS, IN THE HOPES OF, YOU
KNOW, TRYING TO GET COOPERATION
FROM THE FORMER PRESIDENT,
HIMSELF, AT SOME POINT.
AND THIS ADVISOR WENT ON TO SAY
THAT MANY OF THEM FEEL LIKE IT'S
A GOOD THING THAT THERY WERE
USING ENCRYPTED MESSAGING TO
SPEAK WITH ONE ANOTHER DURING
THIS TIME IN THE RUN-UP TO THE
JANUARY-6th INSURRECTION.
AND SO, THAT GIVES YOU A SENSE
AS TO HOW THEY WERE THINKING IN
ADVANCE THAT WHAT THEY WERE
DOING MIGHT NOT GO OVER WELL
FROM A LEGAL STANDPOINT.
THE OTHER THING, ANDERSON, THAT
I THINK NEEDS TO BE SAID IS THAT
ALL OF THIS IS REALLY IN THE
HANDS OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL,
MAERRICK GARLAND.
IF HE IS NOT GOING TO FORCE THE
SUBPOENA THAT STEVE BANNON IS
THUMBING HIS NOSE AT RIGHT NOW,
THE REST OF THESE SIX, ANYBODY
ELSE WHO RECEIVES A SUBPOENA
FROM CONGRESS COULD DO THE EXACT
SAME THING AND HONESTLY THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD JUST BE,
YOU KNOW -- YOU KNOW, HAVE EVERY
RED-BLOODED AMERICAN OUT THERE
PISSED AS HELL THAT THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH CAN THUMB ITS
NOSE AT THE LEGISLATIVE BRANCH
AND THE JUDICIAL BRANCH WHEN IT
COMES TO SOMETHING AS IMPORTANT
AND AS INSANE AS A COUP AIMED AT
OVERTURNING THE ELECTION
RESULTS.
>> MS. HOLTZMAN, HOW CRUCIAL
WILL THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE'S
DECISION TO EITHER PROSECUTE OR
NOT PROSECUTE STEVE BANNON BE IN
GETTING THESE TRUMP ALLIES TO
COOPERATE WITH THE SELECT
COMMITTEE?
>> I THINK IT'S VITAL.
I THINK THE COMMITTEE'S GOTTEN A
LOT OF INFORMATION.
WE HEAR FROM THE LOWER-LEVEL
PEOPLE, THE UNDERLINGS WHO
APPARENTLY COOPERATED OR TALKED
TO THEM.
I MEAN, THEY SAY -- THE
COMMITTEE SAYS THEY HAVE
INTERVIEWED 150 PEOPLE.
BUT THESE ARE THE KEY PEOPLE,
AND THEIR TESTIMONY IS VITAL.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT CAN BE TAKING
THIS KIND OF LAID-BACK APPROACH.
TWO PROBLEMS WITH THAT.
ONE IS THE CLOCK, WHICH IS
RUNNING.
IT'S POSSIBLE THAT IF THE
REPUBLICANS TAKE OVER THE HOUSE
IN THE NEXT -- IN THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS -- WE CAN HAVE A VERY
DIFFERENT SITUATION.
SO, IT BEHOOVES THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO MOVE PROMPTLY ON
THIS.
BUT THE SECOND THING IS, AS JIM
SAID, CONGRESS -- CONGRESS CAN
SUBPOENA INFORMATION AND GET
INFORMATION.
AND IN THIS CASE, IT'S NOT
INFORMATION ABOUT JUST ANYTHING.
IT'S INFORMATION ABOUT AN
ATTEMPT TO OVERTHROW A
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION BY FORCE.
IF CONGRESS CAN'T GET THAT
INFORMATION, THEN WHAT
INFORMATION CAN IT GET?
I MEAN, DURING THE IMPEACHMENT
OF NIXON, WE TRIED TO GET -- WE
SUBPOENAED INFORMATION.
THE PRESIDENT STONEWALLED US AND
ULTIMATELY THE SUPREME COURT
RULED.
AND THAT WAS VITAL IN GETTING
EVERY SINGLE REPUBLICAN ON THE
HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND I
THINK ALMOST EVERY REPUBLICAN IN
CONGRESS WAS GOING TO VOTE FOR
HIS REMOVAL.
>> YEAH.
>> WE HAVE A MASSIVE COVERUP
GOING ON NOW AND THE PRESIDENT
SHOULD BE ASHAMED ABOUT IT BUT
WE HAVE TO CALL IT FOR WHAT IT
IS.
AND THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HAS
TO BE PART OF THE SOLUTION TO
THIS PROBLEM, WHICH IS TO BRING
THE DOCUMENTS, BRING THE
TESTIMONY TO LIGHT.
WHAT THE TRUTH IS CAN ONLY FIND
OUT BY DOING THAT.
>> JIM, OBVIOUSLY, THE WHITE
HOUSE DOESN'T WANT TO BE SEEN AS
PRESSURING AND -- AND -- YOU
KNOW, PRESIDENT BIDEN ALREADY
RECEIVED CRITICISM AND ACTUALLY
APOLOGIZED FOR -- OR AT LEAST
SAID IT WAS THE WRONG THING TO
DO WHEN HE SAID THAT HE THOUGHT,
YOU KNOW, THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
SHOULD -- SHOULD MOVE FORWARD.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
AND I THINK THAT IS WHY, YOU
KNOW, THIS IS REALLY ALL ON THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AT THIS POINT.
AND THAT'S WHY YOU HAVE SO MANY
DEMOCRATS WHO ARE JUST HOPPING
MAD WITH MERRICK GARLAND.
I TALKED TO A HOUSE DEMOCRAT
EARLIER-THIS EVENING WHO SAID
THEY WANT TO SEE TRUMP AND HIS
ASSOCIATES HELD ACCOUNTABLE AND
IF THEY ARE NOT GOING TO
COOPERATE WITH THE JANUARY-6th
COMMITTEE, THAT THEY SHOULD BE
PROSECUTED.
THAT -- THAT IS A -- THAT IS A
VERY BASELINE FEELING AMONG A
LOT OF DEMOCRATS.
BUT, LISTEN.
YOU KNOW, THEY'RE -- WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE LIKE
MICHAEL FLYNN, WHO ALREADY WAS
IN TROUBLE ONCE BEFORE FOR LYING
TO FEDERAL INVESTIGATORS.
RECEIVED A PARDON FROM THE
FORMER PRESIDENT.
I MEAN, THESE ARE THE KINDS OF
PEOPLE THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH.
OF COURSE, THEY ARE NOT GOING TO
COOPERATE.
AND SO, YOU KNOW, AS ELIZABETH
WAS SAYING, WE'RE FACED WITH A
CHOICE.
DO CONGRESSIONAL SUBPOENAS FROM
THIS POINT FORWARD CARRY THE
SAME LEGAL WEIGHT AS A HALLMARK
CARD?
PRETTY PLEASE, MOTHER, MAY I?
WILL YOU COOPERATE WITH THE
JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE?
WE JUST CAN'T HAVE THAT KIND OF
SYSTEM OF GOVERNMENT IN THIS
COUNTRY.
OR ELSE YOU ARE GOING TO GIVE
THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH ALL THE
POWER IN THE WORLD TO DO
WHATEVER THEY WANT FROM HERE
UNTIL KINGDOM COME.
AND, ANDERSON, THE REPUBLICANS
NEED TO THINK ABOUT THIS.
THEY VERY WELL COULD BE IN
CHARGE COME NEXT NOV,EMBER, IN
YEAR FROM NOW.
DO THEY WANT TO HAVE THEIR
SUBPOENAS ESSENTIALLY BE
DECLARED NULL AND VOID AND HAVE
NO LEGAL WEIGHT WHATSOEVER?
BECAUSE THAT IS THE PRECEDENT
THAT THEY ARE SETTING RIGHT NOW.
>> CONGRESSWOMAN, IF YOU WERE ON
THE SELECT COMMITTEE, WHAT WOULD
YOU WANT TO BE HEARING FROM THE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN SUBPOENAED?
>> WELL, I'D, FIRST OF ALL, WANT
TO SEE THE DOCUMENTS, THE
E-MAILS BEFORE I QUESTION THEM.
BUT BASICALLY, I'D LIKE TO SEE,
FOR EXAMPLE, FROM MICHAEL FLYNN.
WHAT HE PROPOSED ABOUT MARTIAL
LAW AND WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
SAID TO HIM IN -- IN RESPONSE TO
THE PROPOSAL.
WAS THE PRESIDENT WILLING TO GO
ALONG WITH USING MARTIAL LAW?
WITH USING THE MILITARY TO
OVERTURN AN ELECTION?
WERE WE THERE?
WE OUGHT TO KNOW MORE ABOUT WHAT
JOHN EASTMAN SAID TO THE
PRESIDENT AND WHAT THE PRESIDENT
SAID TO HIM.
AND UH, SO THOSE ARE REALLY
CRITICAL THINGS.
WHAT THE PRESIDENT KNEW AND WHEN
HE KNEW IT.
THE SAME QUESTIONS THAT WE --
THAT CAME